[Music]
tonight I'm reviewing a game that hasn't
even been released yet it's a very
highly anticipated game this is a real
scoop for us Resident Evil 6 enjoy hey
Colonel Brian here with clueless gamer
and this one is exciting Capcom has seen
some of my reviews for some reason
they're impressed they think I know what
I'm talking about so they've asked me to
review Resident Evil 6 highly
anticipated they're coming out with a
demo on September 18th and they're
giving me the first look and let's bring
my friend in Aaron Blair hey Blaine
hello see you tell us a little bit about
the world of Resident Evil this is the
sixth one so it's kind of a long story
but basically on the Umbrella
Corporation I created this thing called
the t-virus in secret July of dawn I
don't know players it's busy turn people
into zombies zombies that was Resident
Evil 1 a company was making a virus that
turns people into zombies terrible idea
and then suddenly it just happens to get
loose I never understand that what are
you doing working on something that if
it if it's exposed with destroy humanity
as long as it doesn't get out it should
be ok achoo
ok we're gonna start the game now what
happens first it's just gonna give us a
little bit of backstory a little bit of
backstory here we go
except me yeah that's you I'm hot so
basically what happened is the present
United States going to blow the lid off
of the whole government cover-up that
the umbrella corporation created
zomick's and then he got turned into a
zombie so the president this is on me
yeah he's is up how many people in the
country are zombies that will determine
whether he's real acted that was
incredibly violent wait
I just saved her life right yes you'd
think she'd sleep with me okay
so we're in a room now like this I get
really close towards who she does
good point in real life women say
something get away from me funny Conan
leave me alone I have a boyfriend all
right I want to shoot something what's
that
only one way to find out Oh block there
great there's a hoarder living here
passionately can't get over chairs in
way cool guy with gun
blocked by small folding chairs okay
that zombie has died of natural causes
by now Oh something behind this door
this better be a zombie this better be a
freaking zombie look it's her producer
Jeff Ross is that a well-tailored Jewish
man who produces television is in the
kitchen coughing that's it a bigger
threat we got a show to do having
trouble booking the second guest this is
me shut up Jeff listen to me you can
lead with Taylor Lautner you can kiss
lucky yes trust me but okay that's good
let's get some soup any time to fight
zombies yeah well how do I do that
okay this is super cool because this is
the demo that I've never seen the
internet before and there's no one on
the Internet has seen this yet the irony
being I'm the first to play this yet I'm
the least qualified I don't know what
I'm doing and I really don't care so
they made you so okay around this corner
are gonna be three zombies what do I do
basically you're gonna sneak up behind
one of them with this and then use the
right trigger and try to just keep
kicking them these aren't even these are
pinatas yes oh man
fantastic nice no oh wait now just a
good job
how hold the red button yeah and press
one of the top ones I printed
complementor and I almost kicked her all
I'm trying to do is complet the
beautiful girl good work look at her
she's looking at me like nice good work
[Applause]
good work
nice appreciate it nice nice good work
good work
yeah go wow what's what they've eating
sushi that is sushi some kind of
crostini wine guys hungry oh I see a
zombie up there yeah time to kill home
nice
ah she's got to be impressed right I
know I did not equip myself very well
for a while there but I got it together
and I totally blew that zombie away good
work Elaine Ruth did you cooled I spent
a little less time leather jacket
shopping and just come up with another
move Oh God they're fighting you Oh
oh my god do you see what I just did I
started like 50 times handle it man I
can't handle it okay oh wait this parts
just gonna shoot just shoot the right
trigger to shoot them in the hay keep
shooting yeah let's work together out
this is not the right way to play this
survival knife yeah oh oh yeah oh that's
his freaking head off you can play three
different teams in this game so now
we're Jake the thing about Jake is his
blood contains the secret to solving the
C virus so far it's just Hollywood
telling the same old story some kind of
pasta is coming out of his arm why is he
trying to buck Oh God oh he's got the
girl oh no one touches her she's nine
whoa
Cooper goodness
lobster arm yeah all this guy needs to
defeat him now is tartar sauce
that's how we defeat the lobster man
time to melt the butter oh well those
are those lizard guys that are new
basically just turning into some kind of
shellfish round house yeah okay
we've played for a while and here are my
thoughts on Resident Evil 6 great
graphics first time I've ever killed
anything in a game that was exciting
not since pong have I dominated like
this backstory way too complicated
and zombie genre should be simple okay
see zombie kill zombie I don't like them
turning into pasta and then turning into
shellfish shrimp mmm it's confusing and
it made me hungry so on a scale of 1 to
1,500 1,400 being not so good but 1,100
being fantastic and anything and the
negative numbers being even better I
give this a 35 look for this game on
September 18th that's when the demo is
coming out and it's Resident Evil 6 I
hope this helped
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]